Donald Trump started posting
uncontrollably to truth social after we
learned last night that he has been
indicted federally and will have to
appear in Miami on Tuesday first and
foremost if you just sort of like scroll
through
Trump's truth social
every few minutes there's a post it's
either a meme or a video or people
praying with Trump or Republicans
supporting Trump and you can scroll
scroll scroll like we're just scrolling
here endlessly and there is just no
shortage of this stuff truth social
apparently having some glitches but
Trump's spending hours and hours and
hours posting this stuff one of the
first things he did last night upon the
indictment was post a video which we
will look at in a moment but just before
that he posted a three truth rant which
reads as follows the corrupt Biden
Administration has informed my attorneys
that I have been indicted
with a capital i
seemingly over the boxes hoax even
though Joe Biden has 1850 boxes at the
University of Delaware additional boxes
in Chinatown DC with even more boxes at
the University of Pennsylvania
and documents strewn all over his garage
floor where he Parks his Corvette which
is secured by only a garage door that is
paper thin and open much of the time
this is a former president ladies and
gentlemen page two I have been summoned
to appear at the federal courthouse in
Miami on Tuesday at 3 P.M I never
thought it possible that such a thing
could happen to a former president of
the United States who received far more
votes than any sitting president in the
capital H history of our Capital C
country and is currently leading by far
all capital c candidates both Democrat
and Republican in capital P polls of the
2024 presidential election I am an
innocent man and lastly on page three
this is indeed a dark day for the United
States of America we are a country in
serious and Rapid decline but together
we will make America great again now
we're going to look at the video
but the most important point about all
of this that I can make to you
and that is important not to lose sight
of as we are going to see the fire hose
of propaganda really get ramped up over
the next few weeks and days and months
there are those on the right who want
you to believe
that because Donald Trump is being
indicted the system is broken they point
to the Trump indictment and say see this
is the problem with the country are
institutions aren't trustworthy we are a
nation in Decline this is all bad
and they couldn't be more wrong the
indictments of trump prove that at least
at this point in the process no one is
above the law they love to say if they
can do it to Trump they could do it to
anybody we knew that they could do it to
anybody and we know that when we say
there's a two-tier justice system we
talk about the wealthy and Elite with
access to the best lawyers and unlimited
money for defenses and everybody else we
knew about the two-tier justice system
they want to tell you the two to your
justice system is left Wingers and
right-wingers there is no evidence of
that
and what we have to accept
if we honestly assess the situation is
that Trump's indictments tell us no one
is above the law that's a good thing now
whether he will get special treatment in
later phases of this remains to be seen
here's Trump's video that he put out
it's very stupid
very sadly We're a nation of decline
and yet they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country irrelevant to
whether one committed a crime of course
by far
ended much better the second time in the
election than
the first irrelevant and they go after
him on a Box's house just like the
russia-russia Russia hoax and all of the
others this has been going on for seven
years they can't stop because it's
election interference at the highest
level there's never been anything like
what's happened I'm an innocent man I'm
an innocent person they had the Mueller
hoax the Mueller report and that came
out no collusion after two and a half
years well I'm convinced that was set up
by Hillary Clinton and Democrats but
this is what they do this is what they
do so well if they would devote their
energies to honesty and integrity would
be a lot better for our country all
right so it's basically the typical
grievances from Trump after a three
trust trust after a three truth screed
on Truth Central so Trump losing it but
this is nothing compared to Fox News
host Mark Levin